et d'écologie il en est question pour le
premier tour des élections municipales j
- avant ce premier tour c'est le
dimanche 15 mars
la notion d'éco quartier revient
constamment dans les idées des candidats
allaient régulièrement cité pour les
villes on parle de ce dispositif avec
nicolas landry bonsoir bonsoir briques
de la rédaction de tv 78 alors qu'est ce
qu'un écoquartier et d'un gorille est un
éco quartier c'est un label que peut
obtenir un projet d'aménagement qui
prend en compte les principes du
développement durable
à l'origine de cette appellation la loi
de programmation relative à la mise en
oeuvre du grenelle de l'environnement
c'est un texte qui date de 2009 et à
l'article 7 alinéa 3 on regarde on voit
que l'état encouragera la réalisation
par les collectivités territoriales
d'opérations exemplaires d'aménagement
durable des territoires
il mettra en avant un plan d'action pour
inciter les collectivités territoriales
à réaliser des écoquartiers avant 2012
en fournissant à ses collectivités des
référentiels une assistance technique
pour la conception et la réalisation des
projets concrètement si on regarde dans
le détail qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière ce
label le label ecoquartier est basé sur
quatre dimensions on retrouve les trois
piliers du développement durable qui
sont le cadre de vie et l' usage pour le
social le développement territorial pour
l'aspect économique et l'environnement
et climat pour l'écologie dernière
dimension la démarche et processus pour
la gouvernance du projet alors ses
dimensions sont déclinés en vain un
engagement par exemple on retrouve
formaliser et mettre en oeuvre un
processus participatif avec les citoyens
mettre en oeuvre les conditions du vivre
ensemble contribuer à un développement
économique local équilibré et solidaire
ou encore favoriser les moyens de
déplacements collectifs et alternatifs
comment fonctionne cette labellisation
nicolas seules les communes et les
intercommunalités peuvent lancer la
demande du label pour un projet
d'aménagement d'un quartier différentes
étapes pour cette labellisation le label
étape 1
c'est la signature de la charte éco
quartier l'étape 2 correspond au
lancement du chantier l'étape 3 la
livraison du projet et l'étape 4 peut se
faire
trois ans après l'étape 3 pour tester et
évaluer la vie dans l'éco-quartier et
pour terminer quels sont les exemples
d'écoquartier dans les yvelines et bien
au total 18 projets sont labellisées ou
encore en cours de labellisation
labellisation regarder ces quelques
exemples dans le département
unique projet classé en étape 4 à
l'heure actuelle c'est le projet des
molières aux mureaux une candidature
vient d'être déposée pour le projet du
secteur peintre médecins du val fourré à
mantes la jolie en est à trois
aménagements déjà livré on retrouve le
quartier du bel air à saint germain en
laye en cours de chantier labellisé
étape de deux projets à
chanteloup-les-vignes le quartier rouget
de lisle à poissy ou encore la zac
renard de saint cyr l'école
enfin plusieurs projets d'aménagement
ont ou vont obtenir le label un mort pas
le valley boua plaisir le quartier de la
remise à voisins le bretonneux et on
retrouve même des communes rurales comme
le perray-en-yvelines ou encore son
champ merci nicolas de nous aider à y
voir plus clair